Je suis toujours malade, j'en ai marre, ça passe pas
Cette information était essentielle
Je ne sais pas si vous connaissez le jeu du Time's up
Ça fait du bruit parce que je suis en train de mettre la caméra en même temps
et on ne perd pas de temps dans le Mental Vlog, ok ?!
Mais moi j'adore ce jeu le Time's Up
Je vais vous expliquer ce que c'est rapidement
mais je vais surtout vous expliquer comment être un tueur à ce jeu de société
Salut
Donc le Time's Up c'est un jeu de société où on met des noms de personnalités, de personnages et on doit se les faire deviner par équipe en 3 phases
Si vous n'avez pas ce jeu, sachez qu'il existe un site, je l'ai trouvé ce matin qui s'appelle "la bulle fle" je vous mets le lien dans la description
qui vous apprend comment faire un petit Time's Up maison en fait sans rien avec un papier et un crayon
Je crois que j'y ai toujours joué comme ça d'ailleurs
Dans le jeu, 3 phases : la première phase, vous devez par équipe faire deviner à l'autre les noms que vous piochez et vous avez le droit de dire tout ce que vous voulez sauf le nom de la personne
C'est ce qui permet aussi de faire deviner des noms qu'on ne connait pas toujours soi-même ou que la personne en face ne connait pas
puisqu'on a une vraie liberté complète et y a un sablier
Deuxième phase, il y a toujours le sablier. Là vous n'avez le droit de prononcer qu'un seul mot
en disant qu'un seul mot la personne en face doit trouver de qui vous parlez.
Troisième phase, c'est la phase du mime et là vous avez compris il faut donc mimer les personnages que vous piochez.
Dis comme ça, les phases ne paraissent pas simple alors qu'en réalité vu qu'on tourne toujours sur les mêmes noms, le même paquet
Au final au fur et à mesure de la partie vous savez un peu qui y a dedans et c'est la dessus qu'on va se baser
Pour optimiser nos chances de gagner au Time's Up
Dans la phase une, moi j'utilise ma table de rappel
Pour ceux qui viendraient d'arriver sur la chaîne et qui ne connaissent pas la table de rappel,
Je vais vous mettre un petit lien dans la description
et en utilisant une table de
rappel complètement classique,
Vous pouvez même juste utiliser une table de 1 à 30
Vous associez,comme ça tous les personnages qui passent, vous vous faites les images mentales et vous les avez de stockés
qui va être très pratique pour la
suite.
Toujours dans la phase 1, si c'est moi qui dois faire deviner à mon partenaire, je vais placer un mot très fort.
en fait, je suis déjà en train d'anticiper la phase 2 et la phase 3
si jamais on retombe nous mêmes
sur ces mêmes cartes.
Par exemple, si je dois faire deviner Tintin, je vais dire :  "tu sais, c'est un personnage de dessins animés,
Il a une houpette ,comme ça,
une grosse houpette jaune
et il a un chien qui s'appelle milou, c'est..."; il va dire Tintin
Si je repioche carte alors j'aurai juste à placer le mot "houpette" en 2e phase. Et,si c'est le mime,
je vais faire ça et je sais déjà que
ça va lui faire un rappel
avec ce qui s'est passé
précédemment en fait vous êtes déjà
en train de modeler la manière de penser
de vos partenaires.
De la même manière,
je prend un crayon, ça montre à quel point c'est sérieux,
si c'est pas vous qui êtes en train de faire deviner une carte
c'est à dire si c'est votre partenaire
ou si c'est l'équipe adverse
faite l'effort au delà de retenir le nom du personnage évidemment,
de repérer un signal fort sur une gestuelle, soit un mot clé,
très fort
que vous allez pouvoir réutiliser
parfois ces mots clés très fort n'ont même aucun rapport avec le personnage.
Ça peut avoir un rapport avec la situation qui est en train de se passer à ce moment là
parce que quelqu'un est en train de faire tomber son verre, par exemple, par terre.
Et vous avez juste besoin de faire voir le verre
et on va se rappeler que c'est la personne et que c’était de tel personnage qu'on parlait
Trouvez ce qu'il y a de plus marquant
Phase 2.
Phase 3
Si c'est vous qui faites deviner un mot,
donc vous placez le mot fort ou le geste fort si c'est un mime
Si c'est pas vous et qu'on vous donne pas les bonnes clés
avec ces méthodes là pour que vous trouviez
Passez en revue votre table de rappel
Si possible, juste avant que ce soit votre tour
parce que ça va vous rafraîchir la mémoire
sur tous les personnages qu'ils restent à trouver
et donc au fur et à mesure qu'on trouve les personnages  dans ces phases là
ça va réduire un petit peu le champs des possibles
et vous allez être beaucoup plus rapide
Parfois, il arrive qu'il reste plus que quelques cartes
et que moi je balance, déjà, tous les noms restants
Oui c'est un peu de l'anti-jeu j'avoue
Je vais balancer les 4 personnages d'affilés
et pareil pour la carte suivante, la carte suivante, puisque j'aurai juste à chaque fois
Un vrai conseil. En phase 1 et en phase 3
donc la phase où l'on parle toujours et la phase des mimes
N'hésitez pas à faire, également des rébus
si vous connaissez pas le personnage ou si vous savez  que la personne en face ne le connait pas
Faire des rébus soit en mime, ou des rébus avec la voix
ça fait gagner beaucoup de temps
En faisant les rébus, on place aussi des mots forts
ou peut être des choses forts pour la suite si c'est en phase 1
Et voilà comme c'est samedi, vous allez peut être voir des amis où
vous allez peut être, à un moment donné, proposé un jeu
et bien vous pourrez faire ce petit Time's Up
et commencer à vous entrainer
Alors forcément si vous êtes pas hyper au taquet sur la table de rappel, c'est pas grave.
Le but, c'est pas de gagner à tout les coups non plus
même si vous pouvez essayer de faire ça mais on perd le plaisir de jouer, quand même
Mais, vous pouvez augmenter vos chances de gagner
et...
moi autant je suis pas mauvais perdant
autant si je peux gagner...
je me porte mieux.
Merci d'avoir regarder cette vidéo
n'oubliez pas de laisser un pouce en l'air
parce que des fois vous aimez bien mais vous oubliez de le mettre
passez un excellent week end, pensez à vous abonner en cliquant ici
juste avant de partir ou juste là en bas à gauche
Et rendez vous demain à 11h.
Tchao !